Bill Cosby victims slam his plan to tour
this year victims of Bill Cosby have
expressed their anger at the comedian's
plan for comeback tour after a sexual
assault conviction was overturned in
2021. Andrew constant who whose
testimony played a crucial role in
Cosby's 2018 conviction said that if
anybody deserves a comeback comeback
tour it's the woman he traumatized and
abused other victims echoed the similar
sentiments expressing their belief that
Cosby's reputation is damaged Beyond
repair and that he will continue to face
protests and negative reactions from
audiences Cosby has been accused of
sexual assaults by around 45 women and
spent three years in prison for the
crime so good idea bad idea I mean all I
think about is that first show if if you
if I'm willing to bet most people would
go to the show just to see who's showing
up 100 to see how they're going to react
for this guy having the audacity to do
this so is he doing it for money I don't
think so I think he's got money is he
doing it because he wants to go set the
record straight bad way of doing it what
do you think about the idea of a man
going on the score
I mean I think the thing about how old
is he he's falling apart one of his eyes
stop probably 80 something years old
dude how old is Bill I'm going to say 85
85 85 years old right Pat either he just
doesn't want to be home he's hours from
being an organ donkey yeah there's two
right either he just does not want to be
home with you know he doesn't want to
deal with that or he's genuinely loves
comedy which I heard I I watched the
comedian which is an old thing with
Jerry Seinfeld and uh orny Adams and
they went to go see uh Bill Cosby in the
theater day shows packed sold out and he
would do Rob I think two and a half
hours and just sit there and people
would come I think he's doing it him
personally he's doing it because he just
bro he's a comedian and he's been locked
up and he's been away think about what
his first joke is going to be think
about the first thing that's gonna come
out of business so I just flew in from
Dallas
from jail who's gonna sell the tickets
to this thing this is I mean this is the
put you to sleep tour sponsored by
roofie you know I mean what are what are
we that's a sponsor I'm this is a very
very weird situation and there's another
comedian that just had a a YouTube video
come out about him I'm not going to say
any names that causes the net worth by
the way I started dancing some canceling
some dates from this other comedian that
had a a documentary come out about him
that's it's not goodbye maybe people if
you have fans some people some fans
don't care it'd be interesting Tom
brought up a good point Who's Gonna sell
tickets to this like Andrew take Got
Deep platformed for misogynistic
comments yeah from PayPal from stripe he
couldn't actually receive income but
this guy was convicted of raping women
he's gonna go out on tour is
Ticketmaster going to be the one that's
gonna sell those tickets we got the
venue too I mean and hotels you know um
Native Americans running the regional
casinos that are very very popular
Choctaw Casino and things like that
which one of those is going to put their
brand up Pat and allow to put Bill
Cosby's name on the big sign in front of
their brand MGM presents Bill Cosby you
know I I don't know I don't see any
major brands distancing them uh
acknowledging him I wanted to promote
this guy I just don't see it who's going
to put their name on a an 85 year old
guy you're going to attach your Your
Wagon to this guy yeah the tail end of
his career when he's trying to like
clean up his legacy you're like all
right and I guarantee you HBO now
presents Bill Cosby hell no I will
guarantee you guys too it'll sell out
like that I don't know watch oh Who the
hell's going You're Gonna dude there's a
demand I don't I don't understand like a
train wreck everyone was uh no no I
don't think it's gonna it's like the
same reason people again cannot wait to
go watch Chris Rock's show the first
time he's gonna talk about what he's
going to talk about you know you guys
see Eddie Murphy's speech this week when
he won and he says Hey 46 years I've
been an actor I've been in the
entertainment business 46 years 41 years
acting this the first time I'm winning
this and he says there's three things I
learned in my career your mind your own
business pay your own taxes and keep
Will Smith's wife out of here
was brilliant what did anything I don't
know what he won but he won for this one
show and very very interesting different
kind of an Eddie Murphy you're seeing
nowadays but but for me with this it's
more about him why is he doing it at 85
okay uh why would you do it what's your
motive of wanting to do it you really
think people gonna
45 women they're saying one or two or
three talking about 45 of them yeah okay
you think that's people gonna be like oh
you're forgiven we'll move on I don't
think so I don't know but he can't leave
his thing about it he can't leave his
house because wherever he goes there's
going to be so maybe that's that's his
only literally Outlet to just get the
hell out and sit in a room where people
like him so he could tell I mean what
are you gonna talk about I don't even
get it he's got a lot to talk about man
president I think he's just trying to
clean up his legacy uh that's
uncleanable five women well okay that we
know can I can I ask the the the panel
some questions I want to give you some
names you tell me the likelihood that
they're guilty or not God you just do
this I'll be on my opinion okay OJ
guilty 100 100 so OJ killed two people
straight up and he's walking around
looking for The Killers he wrote he
tried to release a book that said I
didn't do it but if I did this is only
because I loved her very much remember
that yeah you're at 100 OJ okay
so so Cosby
100 he's
I don't know but back to Cosby we're all
in agreeance that OJ Cosby and Weinstein
are guilty AF yeah all right I'm just
putting that out there that we are
acknowledging the fact that they are
guilty 100 meanwhile OJ's still out
there yeah killing it yeah so we'll see
what this guy Cosby has going on but it
is if I think Tom had nailed it what
uh Revenue I'm sorry what um
location sponsor Ticketmaster any any of
those there's a big difference
conglomerates they're going to promote I
don't get any big difference between
those three and Tate those three were
found guilty convicted Tate's still
going through so you can't even put him
in that category maybe you could put
Michael Jackson in that category yeah
maybe you can put Kevin Spacey on that
category he can't put some people that
are going through it right now that's
why I give down yeah I don't I don't put
in that category and I also look at it
but don't trust in Romanian courts yeah
but go going through this going through
this with uh uh with uh Bill Cosby
I I don't know I'm more I'm more talking
about you're literally not going to win
people over with this you're not so if
you like this clip and you want to watch
another one click right here and if you
want to watch the entire podcast click
right here
[Music]